مجرد ان تصبح رب اسره يتغير كل شيء ابرز
ما يتغير الميزانيه والميزانيه تتغير بناء
على البلد الذي تعيش فيه
وثقافتك الماليه لكن حديثنا اليوم
مشاهدينا عن ميزانيه المدرسه تحديدا من
الروضه حتى تخرج منها الجامعه نريد ان
نتحدث
عفوا نريد ان اتحدث في حلقه اليوم في فقره
اقتصادك عن كيف تستعد ماليا مع قدوم الطفل
المنتظر
المصاريف في في هذا المجال تطول من البسيط
الى المعقد من الزي المدرسي الى الادخار
الى الجامعه طبعا التكلفه قد تكون هائله
وقد تصل الى مليون دولار مع انتهاء
الجامعه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا في الاستوديو مهندس وصانع محتوى
اقتصادي احمد سند اهلا بك استاذ احمد معنا
اهلا صباح النور
اهلا نبدا معك مليون دولار ممكن يكلفنا
تعليم طفلنا من وقت الروضه لغايه الجامعه
هاي كارثه الحقيقه يعني الاحصائيه بتاعه
هيئه المعرفه والتنميه البشريه في دبي
بتقول ان المصاريف تبدا سنويا من 5000
درهم ل 150 الف درهم في السنه للمدرسه
طبعا ده رينج كبير جدا وبيبين لنا قد ايه
ان الفروق بتيجي نتيجه اختلاف الرواتب في
دبي طبعا الرواتب الرنج بتاعها واسعه ومش
دبي بس في اي بلد يعني وكنا اتكلمنا حتى
الاسبوع اللي فات توزع الدخل بتاعك ازاي
وهكذا فدلوقتي الناس بتصرف تقريبا على
تعليم ابنائها من 15 ل 20% من دخلها على
التعليم فلو كل حد داخل بتاعه طبعا بيختلف
عن الثاني فالرنج الواسع ده بالليل فانت
بتحتار هتدخل ابنك انهي مدرسه فيه وهتجهز
الفلوس دي ازاي فعايزين نتكلم في كم نقطه
اساسيه اللي نقدر من خلالها نحكم ايه
المدرسه المناسبه ليك وايه المدرسه
المناسبه للابناءك طيب انا بس عشان نوضح
بانه التعليم في اغلب دول الوطن العربي هي
هو تعليم مجاني ولكن من يذهب اليوم وهذا
الاكثريه اليوم يذهبون الى التعليم الخاص
بالمدارس حتى يضمنوا جوده تعليم لابنائهم
كيف يختار وكيف يقسم هذه الميزانيه صحيح
صحيح دلوقتي اما تبص على التعليم او على
المصاريف بتاعه المدرسه لا تكتفي بس اللي
انت تبص على المصاريف الاساسيه بتاعه
التعليم لازم تدمج فيها اي انشطه اضافيه
لان انت لو دخلت ابنك مدرسه بتقدر تدفع
مصاريف المدرسه دي في السنه ولقيت ان في
انشطه كتير قوي مش هتقدر تقفورد فانت حطيت
ابنك في بيئه معينه هيفضل طول عمره طول
السنين دي حاسس ان هو اقل من زمايله صحيح
فالتفاوت ده ما ينفعش فانت لازم تشوف
امكانياتك قد ايه مش بس على المصاريف
الاساسيه بما يشمل الرحلات بما يشمل اي
اكس او انشطه اضافيه ممكن المدرسه
الاطفال اللي بيروح بيذهبوا لهاي المدرسه
تكون شامله كل مصاريف لان في ناس بتركز بس
على الاقساط الخاصه به التعليم الكتب
ودي نقطه مش مش مناسبه ان انت بس تحكم على
المدرسه من هذا الجهه في تقييمات بتتعمل
نقطه التانيه في تقييمات بتتعمل سنويا على
المدارس ودي مش كثير من الناس بتهتم بيها
يعني مثلا في دبي وفي الامارات بيتعمل
تقييم لكل المدارس الموجوده سواء حكوميه
او خاصه وبتعمل لها بالتفاصيل بالظبط من
ناحيه اللغات اللغه الاولى واللغه التانيه
اهتمامهم بالانشطه اهتمامهم
بالمناهج التعليميه المختلفه وهكذا
غاليه حتى تاخذ تقييم
عالي بالعكس يعني انت لازم تعمل كده اللي
هي كورست انا بدفع كم وباخد في اخر قيمه
تعليميه احمد كمان في عدد الاطفال يتفاوت
طبعا اللي عنده اطفال عدد اطفال اقل
بتلاقيه عاده يذهب انه لمدارس اغلى لكذا
لانه بحس انه هم كلهم الطفلين مثلا اصرف
عليهم ولكن
تعليم الجامعي اصبح الان خصوصا اذا الواحد
بده يبعثوا اولاده يتعلموا في الخارج اصبح
مكلف
وخصوصا اذا كان يعني لا ينتمي لدول بتعطي
امكانيه ابتعاث متى يجب ان نبدا
يعني نحوش مصاري او نحط فلوس على جنب
لتعليم اطفالنا وهن باي عمر يعني زي ما
ناس كتير
تجهزها
دلوقتي ده التعليم قبل المرحله دي فانت لو
مهتمتش ان انت تحوش المبالغ الكافيه ان
الجامعات يعني اغلب الناس اللي شغاله في
الدول العربيه ممكن شركتهم مش بتوفر لهم
ان هم ياخذوا مصاريف الجامعه من خلال
الشركات بتاعتهم ده حتى اللي بيوفر لهم
التعليم ما فيش ما بيتوفرلهمش فجاه بيتصدم
بيلاقي ان هو كان عنده كفر بيتغطى من
المدارس فجاه مطلوب منه كل سنه مبلغ معين
لولد ورا التاني ورا التالت فجاه ما عندوش
الامكانيه ان هو يعمل ده حتى لو رجعوا
بلده الاصليه بيلاقي التعليم ممكن مستواه
ما كانش هو المطلوب ان هو عايزه فلو هو مش
مخطط لعامل الموضوع ده لو بداته عنده خمس
سنين يبقى انت بتحوش له 13 سنه تقدر ان
انت تعمل ده باريحيه بشكل بسيط تحط مبلغ
ثابت ولنفترض ان هو مثلا 500 درهم في
الشهر او 500 جنيه ايا كان المبلغ ويحفزه
لاستثمرته يعني في ناس بتحط لايف في
السقوط الوطنيه مثلا كل شهر بيحط مبلغ
معين وكل سنه بيحط مبلغ معين بعد عشر سنين
بقى عنده مبلغ معين زي الناس كان زمان
بتعمل في دفتر التوفير بيحط مبلغ معين بعد
عدد معين من السنين لقى ان هو تخرج تخلص
يعني ثانويه عامه بقى مبلغ التعليمي
الجماعي عنده جاهز وفي نقطه تانيه خاصه
بالمنح يعني في كثير من الشباب اللي عندهم
مثلا القدرات الرياضيه معينه عندهم مواهب
معينه يقدر عن طريق ان هو ياخذ منح دراسيه
سواء في جامعات هنا في الوطن العربي او في
ايه جامعات هذه اذا الموهبه من من جهه
والعمل الجاد اللي احنا كنا نتكلم عليه في
فقره ثانيه شكرا جزيلا احمد سعد المهندس
وصانع المحتوى الاقتصادي شكرا
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات